if you haven't heard overnight Equifax
released some information that the worst
data breach in the history of data
breaches occurred it's not the largest
but it's the worst and here's what has
happened if you didn't know
Equifax got hacked over the summer they
released that information today a
hundred and forty three million people's
credit bureau reports were invaded in
hacked and the reason it's the worst is
yahoo had a bigger one I had more people
but it wasn't as thorough these people
got your social security number your
date of birth your name your address
they got all the stuff they need to hack
the crud out of you and we're the other
thing they got like a yahoo was like
they got an email address or something
okay but they got everything from
Equifax they cleaned Equifax is plow and
it's bad it is I'm not a hyper guy I'm
not a melodramatic guy but this is bad
and this is the third time recently that
Equifax has been hammered and they're
doing all the correct PR things and you
know Rick White their CEO there's a
wonderful email man that's if you
haven't seen it you should go look at it
on their website you those of you Rick
Smith I'm sorry is a guy's name of the
CEO and chairman of Equifax it is a
study in how to handle the public
relations aspect of a disaster like this
the guy is stellar he does everything
he's supposed to do in this situation
doesn't fix the fact that because of
them a bunch of you were screwed and and
this is the third time recently so even
though they did a great job with the PR
handling of it let me give you a little
piece of information there are several
class-action lawsuits are already
popping up on this and equifax of course
is offering free monitoring and
free credit repair brought to you by the
people who got hacked so I mean it's a
nice offer but that's kind of stupid all
right and here's the worst part of it if
you sign up for the free monitoring you
in the fine print will waive your right
to sue them little underhanded to stick
that in the fine print that you can't
participate in the class-action lawsuit
because they're the ones that screwed
you I mean they didn't do it
intentionally but this is the largest
debt you know this is the largest
largest database of all of our stuff
that they took from us without our
permission I didn't turn over anything
dekma facts they scarfed it and built a
file on me they did on you too they
collect data on you that's how they
create your credit score you didn't send
them any of that isn't a voluntary
process and it's certainly not a
government agency and and so you know
those of you that worship at the FICO
score here's the price you pay oh and by
the way a bunch of people are tweeting
going Dave Ramsey listeners people who
don't borrow money you know don't have a
credit score I'm really glad I don't
have a credit score it's no big deal
they're not gonna get hit yeah they are
my wife's got hit she was one of them
and that's an account that has a zero
credit score and has been frozen for
probably a decade so even if your credit
was frozen and even if you have no
credit score they still got all your
stuff my personal assistants got hit so
there's the deal now that's all the bad
news bad news is Equifax sucks wow
that's not really news okay and they're
gonna screw you again if you sign up for
their free monitoring because you're not
gonna get beat you know you're not gonna
be able to be included any in
class-action lawsuits which I'm not
gonna do personally anyway but I just
think that's slimy you stand in front of
the camera and go we're so very sorry
we're so sorry
we've worked in hard and been diligent
and done everything we wanted to do and
but we're sorry but yeah when you sign
this on the fine print you give up your
right to do a class-action
just wrong just tells you what's really
going on in places like that so I mean
that they collect your data against your
will use it for their profit and then
don't protect it that's pretty bad so
what do you do if you're one of the
hundred and forty three million what we
do with Sharon Ramsey you know what do
we do
well Shan Ramsay has Xander insurance
identity theft protection which means
that if the thieves were to use her data
there's no indication yet that it has
been used just that it's been stolen if
they were to use her data to open an
account and it shows up and fry a
fraudulent account a medical account a
fraud you know social security account a
fraudulent tax account a fraudulent dad
account they open up debt open up a
credit card insuring Ramsey's name that
will be humorous with it because for
divorce if she did it but if they do it
it's but if they were to do that then
xander identity theft protection which
you can buy today by the way and I would
suggest you do that because they don't
have any fine parentheses you can't
class action Equifax is but and their
stuff right they're an independent
operation and the difference is not just
monitoring you don't want to just get
somebody that monitors your credit
bureau report or monitors you for
identity theft
you want someone who has a caseworker
that takes over all the work and handles
cleaning up the mess if someone utilizes
this theft of identity in order to in
order to open accounts the problem is
not that you owe money the problem is
you have to go through all this hassle
and paying the but working with the
credit card company that you didn't do
anything with and that you don't know
any money to what you're trying to
explain to them that's I'm scum burger
out of a hundred and forty three million
people which by the way there's 300
million people in the u.s. a whole bunch
of them are infants and children and a
bunch of people are off the grid
completely that absolutely have no data
whatsoever
and so out of three hundred million one
hundred and forty three million is like
everybody that's I mean it's it
percentage of the data that they it's
like they got all of it just about I
mean you think about that that's
unbelievable and how they not have any
kind of cyber security alarms that go
off before something gets this far in
and beyond me I mean I understand it can
happen it could happen to us
anybody can get hit and by the way your
data is gonna get stolen by somebody
just kind of super aggravating when it's
those people and so you need identity
theft protection everyone does I've got
it on me I got on my whole family I'd
buy from a whole team so go to Xandar
insurance.com and get that we'll talk
more about this
okay back on the worst data breach in
history the largest theft of importance
detailed information on you 143 million
of you
Equifax got cleaned out and again their
CEO and chairman Rick Smith that a
fabulous job on the PR but there's a lot
of stuff that's not right here
one being that if you sign up for the
free monitoring that they're offering
you are down in the fine print being
required to give up your right to be
involved in a class-action lawsuit which
I wouldn't have you to do that anyway so
the second thing that has come out is
three this from Bloomberg three Equifax
senior executives sold shares stock sold
their own stock worth one point eight
million dollars in the days after the
company discovered a security breach
that may have compromised information on
a hundred and forty three million US
consumers the trio had not yet been
informed of the incident the company
said late Thursday the credit reports
they sold stock after it was discovered
but supposedly these guys didn't know it
before it was public because you know
what their stocks doing today
right I mean it's tanking and so credit
reporting service said earlier in a
statement that had discovered the
intrusion on July 29th and regulatory
filings show that on August 1st chief
financial officer John gamble sold
shares worth nine hundred and forty six
thousand three or seventy four dollars
and Joseph Lundgren president of us
information solutions exercised options
to dispose of five hundred eighty four
thousand now let me help you with this
the chief financial officer the CFO of
the organization and the guy in charge
of us information solutions didn't know
that there'd been a data breach
[Laughter]
really really your Chifa your CFO
doesn't know he should be fired just for
being incompetent if your CFO doesn't
know you've had a data breach your CFO's
an idiot I mean you guys are awful so
yeah he knew I'm sorry I don't believe
you
I mean if it was you know junior third
baseman second fifteenth the guy on the
bench guy he might not have known but
the freaking CFO of a publicly traded
company has a hundred and forty three
million data breach he knows
instantaneously he's one of the first
that's informed he probably knew before
the Chairman's board knew and if he
didn't it just shows how incompetent you
people are so in either case you're a
but you're a joke you're just a joke
unbelievable now how does this affect
you this is all this important other
than me trashing Equifax which I just
love doing but you guys know how bad I
hate the FICO score anyway right I mean
you know how I hate you being forced in
our culture to worship at the altar of
the great FICO and you spend all your
money trying to run your score up by
borrowing money so that you can borrow
more money and all this crap that these
people have looped you into and then on
top of that they you know she's
unbelievable so I mean hey everybody can
have a data breach I mean Ramsey
solutions could be having a data breach
as I speak and I wouldn't know it until
the other day but I wouldn't know it but
they would call me at 2:00 a.m. and wake
me up okay my guys would not if we're
just a little bitty unsophisticated
company compared to this one so anyway
what do you do if you're one of the
hundred forty three million the first
thing you do is you freeze your credit
bureau account and if you haven't you
need to freeze it it's going to cost you
a little money but that helps because
anyone who let's say something let's say
the thieves took your name and applied
for a visa card at Bank of America now
Bank of America issues about eight out
of ten visas without checking credit
so they're going to issue the card
unless you're one of the two out of ten
if you're one of the two out of ten they
check your credit and it's frozen the
card would be denied the thief would not
get to use your identity so a frozen
account does help it doesn't guarantee
but it does help so that's step one step
two is you monitor it you pull copies of
your credit bureau report all three of
them not just Equifax --is you pull them
once a year you should be looking at
them once a year anyway just because I'm
not saying you're trying to run up your
credit score I'm not saying you care
about your credit I'm not saying that
but you just thought to check in on your
electronic reputation and make sure that
somebody's not screwing around with your
stuff right so you need to you monitor
it that's just a smart thing to do
that's just good financial planning to
start with okay you monitor it you
freeze it you have to unfreeze it to
check and then freeze it back cost you
20 bucks or whatever just do it okay
shut up
don't try don't wait on Equifax to fix
your problem because obviously they
don't have your best interest at heart
Oh Lord and then you need to get
something like Xander insurance as
identity theft now you guys think I've
turned this into an ad but there's a
reason that I carry identity theft
insurance it's because people freaking
steal identity all the time from
everybody I mean you got target you got
t.j.maxx you got the government you got
Yahoo and now you got Equifax for the
third time has been violated and they
get your information they're gonna get
your information somewhere if you
haven't had a debit card or you those of
you who still use a credit card shut
down due to fraudulent transactions and
the algorithm pops up you're pretty
unusual my debit card was shut down six
weeks ago somebody picked up the number
somewhere started charging stuff at
places that they've never attends and so
we went yeah probably not me at that one
yeah can you imagine yeah so yeah the
algorithm caught that and I wasn't in
Mexico go figure who knew and so you
know shut it down so you're gonna get
your identity theft stolen you need
something like identity theft protection
now remember if your identity gets
stolen
your problem is not that you owe the
money if someone takes my wife's name
which was one of the hundred and forty
three million they got stolen and opens
an account in her name I don't know any
money sharing don't know any money you
don't owe money when someone steals your
stuff okay but you have to convince the
idiots that open the account in my
example earlier the idiot would be Bank
of America right they issued a credit
card without checking credit which makes
them an idiot okay but we already knew
they were idiots it's freaking Bank of
America okay so you you know they didn't
check so now there's a credit card
opened in Sharon Ramsey's name floating
around out there
because somebody stole her information
from Equifax and opened the Bank of
America Visa Card this is an example it
hasn't happened okay it's not going to
happen but then the problem is I can
call Bank of America and get their
fraud-victim division on the line and
the first thing you have to do spend the
first 45 minutes of my life convincing
these idiots that we didn't actually
open the account and then we just didn't
want to pay it so we're claiming fraud
the first thing they do is accuse you at
the fair of victim division of the
credit card company of being the thief
and you have to explain them look at
doofus we're not paying this you don't
have her signature on file you don't
have our handwriting on file we're not
legally obligated well you have to file
a police report yeah I will be filing
that police report well you're gonna
have to sign affidavits yep I'll be
signing those affidavits but guess what
if you have something like xander
insurances I did any that protection the
real the good identity theft protection
they don't just do monitoring they don't
just do freezing they take over the
problem and there's a caseworker that
cause Bank of America for us and Sharon
and I won't have to deal with it and
they take care of all this crap and then
it's the hundred hours per account that
it takes to clean this crap up that's
the problem it's not that you actually
owe money it's that it's a drain on your
productivity and now the very marrow of
your bones and that's what you need to
do so freeze your account monitor your
account yourself and make sure you've
got identity theft protection and it's
not too late to have ID theft protection
because again the reason this is so
serious the reason I'm taking two entire
segments on this is the misbehavior by
Equifax in their handling of this the
sale of insider trading of stock number
one and number two the fine print
in the agreement you sign that we
believes you have the ability to
participate the class-action lawsuit
pretty underhanded and I'll guarantee
you that's not pointed out to you when
it's sent to you stuff you get only on
the Dave Ramsey show but yeah but the
things you can do are what's important
so you monitor it you freeze your
account you get identity theft
protection because no one has you as
stolen your identity yet they just stole
your information it might not ever
actually get used prey that's what I
pray I hope it never gets used out
there's never a problem for any of you
but that's kind of unlikely cuz some
Russian mobster somewhere now has your
numbers this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]